foreign
here in this video we will showcase to
you all the 15 biggest roles from movies
and shows let's get to it
number 15 the mole troll from The
Spiderwick Chronicles we have the first
troll in this list the mole troll
initially started off as a water troll
in the conceptual stage but was altered
to be a borrowing creature with a long
snout and a muscular body this creature
looks to be around 2.1 meters or 7 feet
tall number 14 Mr wink this one is from
Hellboy to the Golden Army and he is a
cave troll which are strong dim with the
creatures but with a pension for
mechanics they are quite intelligent in
building things but not so smart in
other things they also have strong
manibles for when they are in danger and
a very muscular body he is 2.4 meters or
8 feet tall
number 13 the Horned Troll coming from
the Beowulf series we have the trolls
that have antlers and horns fully grown
these powerful animals stand about 10
feet tall they spot large Rich horns
growing from thickened skulls but the
males have another thing a thicker back
belt like those of a Silverback Gorilla
number 12 the stone and War trolls these
two entries are from The Lord of the
Rings and The Hobbit movies both trolls
are different subspecies but they both
have the same size measurements being
around 10 to 12 feet tall or 3 to 3.6
meters in height stone trolls are the
ones that Bilbo met in the troll Shores
number 11 the bathroom troll this troll
is also called a bathroom Troll and
appeared in Harry Potter 12 feet tall
with skin that is dull granite gray it
has a great lumpy body like a bowler
with its small bald head perch on top of
it like a coconut it also had short legs
take us three trunks with flat and horny
feet number 10 the forest troll this
troll appeared in Snow White and the
Huntsman and is a species of magical
humanoid being that left deep in the
dark Forest they are massive with long
antler-like horns similar to branches
and their skin is like stone with the
growth of moss all over which they can
use to blend themselves in to their
environment
number nine the cave troll this is the
first troll to be seen in a lot of the
Rings In The Fellowship of the Ring it
was encountered by Frodo and Company in
Moria it was the same one that plunged a
spear into Frodo in Balance Doom the
strollers around 12 to 15 feet tall and
like Stone trolls cannot face sunlight
number eight ice troll this strange
troll from rings of power is a snow ice
troll that dwells and The Frigid
wastelands of forward weight it has a
furry bag with stone like outroads has
four large stars jutting out of its
mouth and is really muscular and is
around 4.5 meters or 15 feet tall
number seven the rag of fan this entry
is from the found footage Norwegian
movie troll Hunter these trolls are
hyper aggressive creatures at the
regular fan smaller than others but is
still huge standing at a height of 5
meters or 16.5 feet bigger than a human
being along with rivaling the Star Wars
ranker in size
number six the truncated troll these are
strange and amputated trolls that are
blinded and deformed they were trolls
that were a part of the army of dog will
do led by Azor and were amputated at
both legs and had spiked mazeball
weapons attached to both arms they are
20 to 25 feet or 6 to 7.6 meters tall
number five the mountain troll these are
the biggest trolls from The Lord of the
Rings and The Hobbit series of movies
and are seen in the black Gates of
Mordor they don't seem to possess a good
IQ so to say and work as either shock
troops catapult transport or as the
backbone of heavy labor by Sauron they
are around 25 to 30 feet tall or 7.6 to
9 meters in height
number four the Mountain King this troll
also got the Mountain King as seen in
the movie Ashland and the Mountain King
this troll has a humanoid body with moss
grass and pine tree saplings growing on
his back it's roughly the size of a
three-story building or 30 feet in
height
number three just a lad also seen from
the movie troll Hunter and found the
deep forest the teslad is very thin and
tree sized about 24 meters or 80 feet
tall and as they get older they can
develop several head-like structures on
their body which serve to scare other
trolls or attract trolls of the opposite
sex
number 2 The Troll from the Netflix
movie of this year 2022 is a massive
monster and has an impressive Viking
beard as well this is the Mountain King
troll which hibernated for hundreds of
years is impervious to Modern weapons
and is very tall around 45 meters or 150
feet tall but dies in sunlight
and number one the yotna this is the
biggest role to appear in any movie or
show as of now the stroll is called the
yotun or yodnar it is a mountain troll
one of the three main antagonists of the
film troll Hunter as well as the most
largest subspecies of troll ever known
standing at around 61 meters or 200 feet
tall unfortunately it had rabies
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe and most of all smash the
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam